I did not know him but I you get to know
him on the set because it's like he's so
funny and he's so lovely and I was
actually from the outside he looks like
you know so happy and you know all those
things but when I came back to the show
I had this huge weight on me and nobody
knew nobody but my parents and like
obviously everybody involved and then we
all sat down before we're going to go
out to the blinds because and with the
producers as you do right before you're
going to go out and we were all in the
couches we were miked up and everything
in Blake's like I got to talk to you
guys and he basically made his
announcement about leaving Miranda yeah
yeah so that was like I think I might
have like went white and like [ __ ] like
I was in shock because it felt like he
was exposing me now it's your turn you
know and I just couldn't even get my
head around it and then it was during
the blinds during that time he he came
up to my chair for the first time he's
ever walked to my chair and he was like
I'm sick from what I think he was just
like and I never saw him like look so
upset jerem saying and then so then I
was like I gotta talk to you and I was
like I didn't I wasn't gonna tell of
anything but I just meant to talk to you
you know and then we ended up talking
and um and you revealed to him you were
having your own problems
kind of yeah I didn't mean he basically
told me what's going on with him and
then I was like well I can't tell you
everything but I'll just say you know so
then we just started this friendship
which was just unbelievable that God
would put us in a position to have each
other at the morning and not like in the
same exact moment